Inserting a new node is
where the magic happens.
There are several different
states of the tree and
the node you're inserting that
require different courses of action.
Remember that your resulting tree needs
to follow both the red-black tree and
BST rules.
There's a lot of information here.
Your first goal should be to watch and
get a sense of how red-black trees work.
You can rewatch the video later
to actually memorize the details.
One overall rule of insertion is that
you should try to insert a node as a red
node, which from here on out
I'll represent as both red and
square to help with differentiation,
and then change its color as needed.
The first situation is when you're
inserting the first node into the tree.
Since it's the root, you can change
the color to black if you're adhering to
the root must be black rule.
Otherwise you'll have nothing to do.
If the new parent node is black,
you don't need to do any work.
Since you're adding a red node,
you haven't upset the balance
of black nodes in any path or
violated any of the other rules.
Now if the parent is red,
there are several cases with
more complicated solutions.
If the parent and
its sibling are both red,
then they should be changed to black.
And their parent, the grandparent,
let's say, of the node you're inserting,
becomes red.
We switch the node colors in this
way to maintain the number of
black nodes in a given path.
Look through all the paths in this tree.
The number of black nodes
in each path is still two.
The biggest problem here is that
we could have violated another
property by changing the grandparent.
We can just treat the grandparent as
a newly inserted node and change it or
its ancestors according to
the same cases and rules.
Here we just treat it like Case 1 and
change it back to black since we
still want the route to be black.